hey Bill so there are many videos online
claiming to be extraterrestrial
sightings at times it seems that the
government is aware of the
extraterrestrials yet they reject the
idea possibly they're hiding the truth
from us in fear of the knowledge greatly
changing our daily lives do you believe
these aliens exist and if so would you
tell us no I don't believe the aliens
exist coming to visit you and the
government knows about it and hasn't
told you know start with that two more
things first of all the whole alien
thing really got revved up in 1947 there
was a project called skyhook and the US
government had these very cool super
high-altitude balloons and they were
going to have a constellation of them or
an armada of these balloons off the east
coast of the former Soviet Union with
microphones tuned to listen for nuclear
weapons tests this was going to be big
fun and so they were testing the balloon
in New Mexico and it was complicated and
the winds blew the thing around and it
crashed and it was impractical the idea
was kind of cool but it was a Cold War
idea that this didn't work now this
project was secret
so yes government of people showed up
the US Army swept up all the debris from
the crash and took it away because it
was secret and they also experimented
with parachuting dummies from very high
altitudes in the same area and this has
led to all these fabulous myths about
aliens and the government knows stuff
you don't know I look like nobody and I
am but I had an engineering job several
of them over the years
and during one of them I had security
clearance and I worked on a secret
airplane for a little while and I never
went myself but I
worked with several guys they're all men
who went to area 51 to groom Lake which
is an Air Force Base in Nevada where we
fly around these secret airplanes and
it's a real place and these guys went
there and in when I was doing it was
called level five security clearance I
only had level four I never went to
groom Lake but the big thing they
wouldn't talk about was how fast these
planes could go that was a big secret
but these are people that worked on the
f-117a stealth fighter if you ever go to
the Air Force Museum in Ohio you can see
the have blue secret planes very cool I
always a kid I always ask myself why
don't they paint spy planes light blue
to blend in with the blue sky well
sometimes they do anyway you can see one
of those there so it's a complete myth
that the government know just think how
hard it is for the government to keep
anything secret the with all do the
government kind of sucks at keeping
secrets so they couldn't possibly keep
the secret with ten thousand people in
on it so let's just set that aside but
with that said you may very well be
alive when we discover life or evidence
of life rather on Mars this would
literally be alien life if we find it if
we find some ancient microbes still
alive in some icy layer under the
Martian sand it would change the world
it would change the way everybody thinks
about being a living thing do these
things on Mars if they exist do they
have DNA or did they have DNA if they've
been fossilized or are they a whole
nother completely type different type of
life that we've never thought of did
life start on Mars Mars got hit with an
impact or and you and I are descended on
Martians that is amazing it's it's not
crazy it's extraordinary but it's not
crazy then furthermore you may be a lot
when we send missions to the moon of
Jupiter called Europa which has at least
twice as much sea water as the earth is
theirs when you have sea water for four
and half billion years
is there something alive on Europa whoa
like dude that's out there it would
change the world it would utterly change
the world these would be this would be
real alien life discovered with tax
dollars by people who are intellectually
curious who decide to devote some of our
intellect and treasure to exploring our
nearby planetary worlds and that's the
real stuff that I encourage you to
support and follow and for that of
course I encourage you to join the
Planetary Society think about that you
don't have to just suggesting because we
really do advocate for the real
exploration exploration of nearby worlds
really looking for alien life also the
John James Webb Space Telescope is going
to launch in 2018 and it may have the
capability it is hope that will have the
capability of exploring atmospheres of
extraordinarily distant planets by
having sunlight from those stars that
those planets orbit pass through the
atmospheres if we detect water vapour
and methane it may mean someday that
we've detected evidence of life on
another world due to tu-tu-tu-tu-tu-tu
so the real stuff is what I'm saying the
real exploration for alien life is more
exciting than speculating about a
nominally secret Air Force Base in
Nevada
carry on
[Music]